[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 78 lactu
sur tvfield 78 le point sur la formation
locale de 50 ans en Yveline à Versailles
voici les titres de ce 22 mai le TS
monte à Febus la direction de la société
de bus à Versailles remporte un premier
bras de fer après 10 jours de blocage du
dépôt par les grévistes à la justice
ordonne aux salariés de libérer les
accès sous peine de sanctions
financièrees le Salon du livre à
saint-ci l'école se déroule ce 24 mai un
salon autour principalement de livre du
livre historique le commissaire général
du rendez-vous et l'invité du journal
toujours en partenariat avec Radio
sensation nous irons aussi à Cann pour
suivre les ivelinois sur la Croisette
Kevin garnicha comédien originaire de
véis présente PIM poum le petit panda
d'Alexis michalic dans le cadre talent
can
2014 la justice a donc ordonné aux
grevistes de la société Febus à
Versailles de laisser leur entreprise
assurer un service minimum pour les
usagers et si sur son site internet la
compagnie de transport en bus annoncéit
aujourd'hui que le blocage se
poursuivait sur place les premiers
véhicules ont pu sortir le point complet
avec Jérémy
ebras ce mercredi au dépôt de Febus à
Versailles l'abattement régnait parmi
les grevistes plus tôt dans la journée
le tribunal a ordonné la fin du blocage
du dépôt David métin avocat des
grevistes not né moins deux
irrégularités dans la décision du
tribunal il a fait appel d'une part il y
avait il y a eu un blocage c'est vrai
mais pas un blocage de l'entreprise et
pas un blocage de l'entrepôt il y a eu
un barrage qui a été fait sur la voie
publique les bus sortaient du dépôt mais
ils étaient bloqués à 50 m du dépôt ça
veut dire que en droit j'insiste en
droit on est sur la voie publique on
n'est pas dans l'entreprise et
d'ailleurs les barrières de la de
l'entreprise était fermé par la
direction l'autre point ce sont les
gréistes si sont ont été assignés on ne
comprend pas pourquoi 220 gréistes sont
expulsés alors que seuls six sont
attrait en justice et le tribunal n'a
pas encore déterminer la date de la
prochaine audience ce jeudi la situation
semblait évoluer dans le bon sens
puisque le dialogue s'est établi entre
les représentants de l'intersyndical
greviste et la direction des
négociations ont commencé ce matin le
trafic en revanche n'est toujours pas
revenu à la normale selon les grvistes
environ 15 % des bus seulement seraient
sortis du dépôt contacté à plusieurs
reprises la direction de Febus n'a pas
donné suite à nos sollicitations pour
rappel les grevistes se plaignent de
conditions de travail qu'il jugent
déplorable et réclam une augmentation
salariale de 5
%. ce jeudi 22 mai c'est la Journée
nationale de prévention de dépistage des
cancers de la peau dans les ivelines
attrape l'Institut de promotion de la
santé proposa des dépistages gratuits
une dizaine de personnes s'est rendu sur
place ce matin l'occasion pour le
dermatologue de rappeler les deux
facteurs essentiels de ces maladies
cutanées d'une part l'aspect génétique
et d'autre part les expositions au
soleil tous les ans 11000 nouveaux cas
de mélanome sont détectés en France
est-il des signé qui alerte quels sont
les types de grains de beauté dangereux
quelques éléments de réponse au micro de
yolen Torz quand le contour devient
asymétrique en carte de géographie quand
la couleur n'est plus
homogène quand il évolue il faut se
méfier et consulter il faut ne pas
s'exposer pendant les heures chaudes de
la journée c'est-à-dire entre en gros
11h et
16h mettre de la des protections
totales ne surtout pas exposer les
enfants de façon importante sur les
plages et puis se faire examiner par un
dermatologue de façon
régulière avantdernier volet à présent
de notre série sur l'Europe avec Europe
Direct dans les ivelines nous avons
choisi de vous expliquer comment
intervenait l'Union dans notre quotidien
ce soir il est question de la création
d'entreprise
l'Europe vous êtes déjà en facilitant
les démarches pour créer votre
entreprise l'Europe essaie notamment
d'instaurer un guichet unique avec une
procédure unique pour les 28 pays donc
une procédure unique pour créer une
entreprise l'Union aussi peut vous
apporter une expérience professionnelle
parce que vous pouvez être un jeune
créateur d'entreprise vous pouvez
souhaiter lancer votre entreprise mais
vous ne savez pas comment faire vous
souhaitez avoir plus de plus de pratique
avoir une véritable expérience en la
matière donc l'Europe a un programme qui
s'appelle Erasmus pour jeunes
entrepreneurs et donc qui vise tout
simplement à envoyer des jeunes
créateurs d'entreprise qui souhaitent
créer leurs entreprises ou qui ont déjà
créé leur entreprise et donc ce
programme leur permet d'aller tout
simplement travailler dans une autre
entreprise à l'étranger dans une PME
dans l'Union européenne et ça va
permettre à ces jeunes entrepreneurs
d'être coaché par un dirigeant qui a
fait ses preuves toute entreprise va
créer quand elle crée des produits ben
va y avoir du du travail intellectuel en
la matière et donc cette cette création
intellectuelle est protégée au niveau de
l'Union européenne via notamment tout ce
qui est les droits d'auteur les droits
d'auteur ont été uniformisés au niveau
de l'Union européenne et notamment aussi
les brevets européens donc on a l'office
européen des brevet qui se trouve à
Munich et aussi pour les marques on a
une protection européenne en la matière
et c'est l'office d'harmonisation des
pour le marché intérieur qui qui se
trouve en Espagne l'Union européenne a
plusieurs instruments financiers pour
aider les créateurs d'entreprises donc
il y en a plusieurs alors on a
principalement donc tout ce qui est la
Banque européenne d'investissement et le
Fond Européen d'Investissement c'est un
peu les équivalents de notre banque
publique d'investissement donc ces
établissements vont vous peuvent vous
prêter de l'argent pour vous lancer euh
pour pour que vous puissiez lancer votre
entreprise après l'union européenne peut
aussi vous mettre en relation avec ce
qu'on appelle des Business Angels qui
vont pouvoir eux vous apporter des fonds
privés culture les iblines à can Nicolas
kirilovitz et Franck David de radio
sensation nous propose de suivre depuis
le début de la semaine le festival à
travers des rencontres avec des acteurs
réalisateurs financeurs du département
ce soir à l'honneur Kevin garnicha il
est comédien originaire de véisie l'un
des 19 comédiens sélectionné parmi 836
postulants pour la première édition de
l'opération talent Cann de l'adamie
passé par le Conservatoire Régional de
versaill il est au générique de Pim poum
le petit panda d'Alexis michalic ce
courtmétrage a été dévoilé à Can semaine
l'histoire une troupe de comédien qui
participe à un goûter d'anniversaire
dans l'espoir d'être repéré par un
professionnel Kevin qui a même dansé et
chanté pour l'occasion et qui a été ravi
de cet accueil par la Croisette je sais
pas moi je trouve ça incroyable j'arrive
pas trop à m'en remettre encore là pour
l'instant je crois que ça va ça va en
même temps je reste pas très longtemps
moi je reste que de jours du coup c'est
c'est chouette parce qu'en fait ça ça va
tellement vite on nous dit va viens ici
va à droite regarde là c'est maintenant
tu montes les marches fais trucs et
demain un soir je repars donc je pense
que j'ai pas trop le temps de prendre la
grosse tête ou que ça me monte à la tête
et j'espère que ça ça me le fera pas
mais c'est impressionnant moi je trouve
ça très
impressionnant enfin moi je vois ça tout
le temps à la télé et de me dire bah on
fait un peu partie du truc aussi
maintenant c'est enfin maintenant juste
pour ce truc c'est pas facile d'être un
panda PIM poum j'ai l'impression que
c'est la première définition du comédien
quoi enfin j'ai l'impression qu'à la
base c'était aussi un un peu ça aussi un
comédien qui peut se servir de son corps
de sa voix de je trouve pas ça du tout
antinomique de
jouer la comédie chanter et danser et au
contraire j'ai l'impression que ouais ça
fait un peu américain ou anglaxon mais
je crois que c'est des modèles qu'il
faut suivre parce que c'est quand même
SAR sacrés comédiens cap de tout
faire il faut aspirer à ça en tout cas
qu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aspire le producteur et agent
artistique Dominique fait une apparition
dans ce age il a eu un coup de cœur pour
Kevin à qui il prédit un bel avenir à
l'image d'un célèbre comédien français
écoutez à côté Pierre Richard donc je
lui souhaite la carrière de pierre
Richard c'est pas moi qui me suis imposé
il trouvait que c était rigolo que
que vu mon âge et ma situation je vien
dans un déjeuner de d'anniversaire une
fête d'anniversaire cette année encore
la 22e édition du tibreak a réuni de
nombreux sportifs à la césive line des
enfants de trappe de versaill de Mont la
jolie qui se sont ici à différentes
activités sportives sous les conseils
avisés de grands champions une action au
profit d'une association SOS gazelle
yolen Torz allez sur 20 c'est parti
allez allonge le bras gauche on a changé
de bras les garçons allonge le bras
gauche 22 ans d'existence et toujours
autant de succès au golfe des ivelines
cette année le tibrek accueille 70
enfants de trappe de Versailles et de
mant-el jolie au programme des ateliers
de karting de box ou encore d'athlétisme
encadrés par des grands champions Ryan
Simon eux s'initient au golf pour la
deuxième fois et s'améliore déjà déjà je
tire plus loin
euh comment dire moi je me suis amélioré
il faut pas forcément tirer fort il faut
bien ouais il faut s'appliquer quoi
maintenant j'arrive à tirer dans la
balle j''y arrivais pas le haut et le
bas tout ça soit ancré c'est comme si on
rentrait ses chaussures dans le sol tu
vois regarde le parrain de cette 22e
édition c'est lui Stéphane fress acteur
de cinéma mais aussi grand passionné de
golf
alors qu'il prodigue quelques conseils
aux enfants Tatiana Golovine marine de
l'événement tente de manier au mieux son
club je pense que c'est vraiment très
important quand on a l'opportunité de
pouvoir venir de d'aider d'intervenir et
surtout de partager son sport ses
connaissances et surtout voilà passer
une belle journée avec les étudiants
avec les jeunes c'est devenu une légende
le tbreak qui ne connaît pas le tbreak
aujourd'hui après 22 ans de de de de de
de vaillant service pour la belle cause
de de l'enfance et du sportif et de la
réunion de ces deux catégorie
c'est-à-dire de ce qui va devenir
peut-être un jour un sportif on part
donc de la base et et et de créer c'est
voilà c'est ces moments très très
conviviaux en parallèle un tournoi de
golf rassemblant une quarantaine de
grands champions étit organisé 100 % des
bénéfices récoltés seront reversés à
l'association SOS gazelle une
association née il y a 12 ans déjà en
voyant tous ces sportifs de haut niveau
champion du monde médaillé olympique
réunies avec derrière une grosse
puissance et médiatique et d'images je
suis dit que ça serait dommage de pas en
faire profiter les plus jeunes les
enfants qui sont notre avenir et comme
j'ai l'habitude de le dire le sport est
rassembleur au-delà des différence dans
une période lourde et difficile après le
Maroc le Cameroun ou encore le Sénégal
l'association finance depuis 2 ans des
centre pour enfants en France des
centres axés sur trois valeurs
l'éducation la santé et le
sport et en marche de cette animation on
vous en parlait d'ailleurs brièvement
dans ce reportage une compétition de
golf é est proposé avec à la clé un
titre de champion des champions le
vainqueur cette année Cédric Piolin
ancien tennisman au total 20 équipes de
quatre champions se sont affrontés parmi
lesquels vous avez pu reconnaître Lionel
chamouot ou encore Alain Roche
rendez-vous lundi prochain dans le 78
sport pour découvrir lors interview à
partir de
18h30 sport de rigur sport de tradition
le tir à l'arc compte à ce jour près de
70000 licenciés un chiffre loin des
autres disciplines mais qui n'empêche
pas à certains de s'y inscrire en
famille Isabelle Patrice et leurs deux
enfants ENF décoche les flèches ensemble
nous les avons rencontrés à Montini le
bretonux où vient de se dérouler les
championnats départementaux un portrait
signé Antony rche si chacun a sa
spécialité il partage désormais une
passion commune pour la cible dans la
famille Rampon l'histoire est désormais
faite d'Arc et de flèches et c'est
d'ailleurs Vincent le fils qui est
arrivé le premier sur le pas de tir et
son père Patrice a vite suivi sa
trajectoire en m'accompagnant sur les
concours parce que sinon je pouvais pas
je pouvais pas y aller donc plus il
m'accompagn sur les concours plus
remarqué qu'au final c'était peut-être
pas si mal que ça donc après ils ont
essayé sollicité par l'entraîneur de la
famille Alexandra Aurélie décoche ses
premières flèches il y a un an et demi
et elle a vite trouvé le centre de la
cible assez rapidement en fait c'est
malheureusement maintenant il y a une
stagnation qui est un petit peu
difficile à accepterin voilà assez
compliqué de gérer la défaite il
s'entraîne désormais deux fois par
semaine et ESS de ensemble aux
compétitions mais évidemment sur le pas
de tir la rivalité est parfois
omniprésente au sein de la famille entre
Vincent Patrice et Alexandra Aurélie
tout le monde veut réussir le meilleur
score Vincent et moi et Alexandra Aurée
qui
tire depuis moins longtemps que nous
parce queelle elle a commencé il y a que
2 ans et donc elle voudrait nous
rattraper très rapidement il a un peu de
mal mais il y arrive donc bon bah
maintenant il y a plus qu'à continuer il
passera peut-être devanti
s'ils n'ont pas fait leur meilleur volet
de la saison sur ce championnat
départemental ces quatre archers auront
passé un moment en famille et c'est bien
là
l'essentiel après l'effort la détente si
les conditions climatiques le permettent
en tout cas chaque année l'été synonyme
de barbecue à la base de loisir àrappe
et avant que la pluie n'arrive le soleil
a brillé en fin de semaine
dernière il n'y a plus aucune place sur
la grille du barbecue la glacière est
pleine pas un nuage aux environs tous
les ingrédients pour une première
après-midi au soleil réussi semblent
réunis est
bien et puis on n pas les uns sur les
autres il y a tellement il y a beaucoup
d'espace voilàace les enfants sont voilà
ils sont de l'espace pour jouer ils sont
tranquilles ils font leur vie ils
peuvent courir chacun ramène à manger et
à boire au menu brochett poulet
saucisses mergise tout est prêt à être
grillé quelques arbres plus loin dans
cette famille d'origine malgache les
hommes s'occupent des grillades les
femmes préparent les salades là c'est du
poulet en fait c'est déjà macéré depuis
ce matin et de la sauce sauce
soja qu'est-ce du poivre du sel en fait
et avec une touche de miel pour l'aspect
sucré en famille entre amis il ne loupe
jamais l'occasion de profiter du soleil
sur 50 ans en Eveline et évidemment
après un tel barbecue la musique permet
de continuer la fête sous le
soleil et il compte bien danser jusqu'à
la tombée de la
nuit ah malheureusement le barbecue sera
difficilement installable ce weekend
météo France annonce de la pluie jusqu'à
dimanche soir l'occasion de privilégier
les manifestations bien à l'abri et
pourquoi pas le Salon du livre de
saincire l'école bravo pour cette
transition je vais me féliciter
maintenant bonsoir Philippe de bouco et
bienvenue merci d'être venu jusqu'à nous
même si la circulation est parfois
difficile entre saint-cè l'école et
Saint-Quentin en Yveline commissaire
général du salon littéire 2014 à
saint-sir salon qui se déroule samedi
après-demain ce sera la 3e édition
particularité associé la lecture et la
découverte du patrimoine de l'histoire
alors pourquoi cette cette thématique
autour du livre historique absolument
ben écoutez d'abord bonsoir
euh on peut pas on peut pas évacuer
l'histoire du lycée militaire c'est
impossible les personnages qui ont fait
qui ont contribué au rayonnement de et
de l'institution d'abord la maison la
maison de Saint-Louis avec Madame de
Maintenon ensuite l'Empereur le ané
impériale et puis l'École spéciale
militaire c'est vrai qu'on peut pas on
peut pas se se s'extraire de de cet
élément- là en revanche on se sert de
cet univers là pour et bien rebondir sur
d'autres types de littérature alors
l'histoire et puis maintenant le roman
historique sont très très présent on a
une littérature aussi on va dire
militaire avec beaucoup de beaucoup de
d'auteurs qui viennent de différents
horizons civils et militaires d'ailleurs
et puis on s'ouvre à tout type de de
littérature la poésie le théâtre le
roman la fiction avec et bien toute une
une gamme d'auteurs plus ou moins
éclectique et ça se déroule au lycée
militaire lu emblématique de cette de
cette ville de saint-cier l'école c'est
occasion l'occasion aussi de découvrir
ce site puisquil est ouvert absolument
c'est la seule fois avec les journées du
patrimoine où le lycée militaire est
ouvert au public c'est vraiment
important que les les sacériens et les
gens autour puissent rentrer dans ce cet
environnement qui fait à peu près le
quart de la ville c'est 25 hectares et
ça leur est ouvert ils peuvent découvrir
la tombe de Madame de Maintenon ce musée
qui est absolument somptueux qui a un
petit écrin directoire dans lequel on on
redécouvre énormément de choses très
intéressantes c'est vraiment l'occasion
aussi de se balader et on en a fait un
un une journée d'animation où on va pas
retrouver simplement du livre on a envie
que les gens puissent se s'amuser manger
boire BO un coup et voilà et passer un
bon moment et tout de même lire un petit
peu he puisque c'est un salon littéraire
alors quels sont les les auteurs présent
est-ce que ce sont des des auteurs
locaux pas forcément alors des auteurs
locaux c'est c'est évident qu'on
privilégie leur leur présence et qu'on
les invite que ça soit qu' soit issu du
département général bien entendu euh on
sait que les villes sont sont dans les
ivelines et bien sont très comment
dirais-je ouvertes à la publication de
de de certains ouvrages les villes comme
les associations euh mais évidemment pas
seulement euh nous avons des gens qui
viennent
d'univers euh très vaste alors des têtes
d'affiche pas forcément parce que l'idée
c'est pas de c'est un petit peu de se
démarquer et cetera en revanche on a des
gens passionnants comme Ben certains
comme des confrères à vous qui soit
journaliste reporter ou j'ai ou
ou on va dire plutôt géopoliticien mais
mais Mame interman nous fait l'honneur
de venir c'est vraiment très ça sera
très intéressant elle va rester un bon
moment en plus on a bien une star locale
avec son padre blog le l'abbé Grogan qui
est sort à je ne sais plus combien de
centaines dizaines de milliers
d'exemplaires euh dans dans le je dirais
la littérature de société voilà nous
avons aussi des des des ambassadeurs des
je crois que c'est on est allé plutôt
chercher des métiers et des gens qui qui
avaient envie de raconter une histoire
et qui avaient envie de nous avons aussi
cette niche qui est plus qu'une niche
puisque il y a une trentaine voire une
quarantaine d'auteurs qui viennent des
oututremèes c'est la troisè fois qu'il
reviennent et ils font le voyage exprès
donc on est très honoré de les recevoir
et cette année aussi on a suivi les
traces du salon de du Salon du livre de
Paris et on accueille les auteurs du
bassin des pays du Congo donc avec une
ouverture supplémentaire donc ilura
forcément pour tous les goûts samedi sur
ce salon littéraire avant que vous nous
disiez si la fréquentation répond bien à
vos attentes depuis la création un micro
trottoir quel est votre livre de chevet
en ce moment et pourquoi vos réponses
Jean-Christophe Granger c'est la suite
des rivières pourpr et cetera voilà je
suis en train de lire le siècle de Ken
folet j'ai toujours un livre sous la
main ou oua ah bah ça me permet de
m'évader d'oublier la journée et de
plonger dans autre chose que le
quotidien dernier arrêt avant le avant
l'abattoire ville vanille ça détend
ça ça permet de se reposer
intellectuellement j'en ai au moins 300
livres chez moi alors j'ai lu beaucoup
je lis beaucoup moins Jack London
aujourd'hui Musau les les romans de ce
style là oui tout à fait d'accord mais
en vacances c'est Blanche-Neige
et la bête et la bête la bête et la Bête
pas mal celui-ci on a entendu beaucoup
de titres toujours des raisons diverses
mais le public aime lire plus de 440
millions d'ouvrages qui se sont vendus
en 2012 ça diminue un petit peu chaque
année mais ça reste tout même très fort
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle voilà
les salons littéraires se portent bien
les gens aiment lire c'est vraiment
excellent et on se rend compte que même
quand en tant qu'organisateur on voit
que ben ça se bouscule au portillon
qu'il y a énormément de réunions et
littéraire dans en particulier c'est ce
qu'on appelle les les spring salon les
gens vont lire pendant leur été il faut
leur donner des choses à à lire il faut
les et c'est vrai qu'on donnera le
programme et bien samedi vous verrez il
y aura beaucoup de choses beaucoup de
choses très intéressantes du
roman de la poésie du théâtre et je vous
donnerai le programme sur place mais une
fois de plus le but c'est ce n'est pas
de faire un rendez-vous élitiste vous
nous l'avez dit c'est'ouvrir au plus
grand nombre c'est très clair c'est
s'ouvrir absolument au plus grand nombre
ça c'est vraiment très important ouvrir
à la littérature et à la ouverte la
fréquentation sur ce salon sur les
précédentes éditions et bien écoutez
c'est un saincire construit son public
donc on va pas dire que c'est le Salon
du livre de Paris mais on était
extrêmement optimiste et on a été C
cette fois-ci aidé par tous les acteurs
des villes voisinante qui tout
simplement ben nous ont sont sont au
courant sont informés et
ont et ont ventiler l'information donc
voilà donc on vous dira ça samedi soir
on sera très heureux de de de compter le
plus grand nombre de visiteurs au
programme notamment exposition café
littéraire aussi et puis des élèves du
collège du collège jean- racine qui
seront présents vous les avez associés
aussi sur ce rendez-vous absolument
c'était très important les les collèges
du les élèves pardon du collège en
racine ainsi que ceux de de du lycée
Mansard Périn et du lycée militaire bien
entendu alors le lycée militaire c'est
un petit peu différent parce que ils
sont chez eux ils sont en weekend donc
c'est vrai qu'on a pas tellement la la
le proviseur n'a pas forcément envie de
les obliger en revanche euh que ce soit
Mansard ou euh ou la la classe avec leur
classe cinéma ou le CDI de Jean Racine
s'associe d'une manière très active
puisque euh notre objectif c'était de
leur faire faire lire certains certains
ouvrages de les mettre en contact avec
certains auteurs mais surtout là il y a
quelque chose de très intéressant c'est
que il se bah le CDI a et la classe du
journal d' encore de jeunes confrères à
vous euh du JT de Jean Racine vont venir
et vont justement filmer le café
littéraire qui aura lieu de 14h30 à 19h
toute la journée avec je dirais un
filage de tous les de tous les auteurs
qui vont passer interrogé par karinan la
romancière euh qui est vraiment
passionnante et qui s'est un petit peu
décortiqué est au-devant au au-dessà des
des des des lignes on va dire on termine
par le clou de cette cérémonie de cette
fête du du livre c'est le prix il y a un
prix qui est remis par la ville quels
sont les critères alors les les critères
c'est euh je crois je je ne fais pas
partie de ce de ce jury même si je je
j'en oriente les les les personn ité euh
c'est que ça soit euh lisible par tout
le monde et que on puisse se retrouver
que ce soit dans la littérature jeunesse
et c que tout le monde puisse s'y
retrouver donc euh voilà ce sont des
critères extrêmement
simples les on doit y trouver du plaisir
voilà et donc les auteurs reçoitent le
jury reçoit certains ouvrages mais vous
savez que c'est un petit peu compliqué
d'envoyer on a quand même presque 80
auteurs donc on n verra pas les 80 les
80 ouvrages mais en revanche ce juris va
se travailler toute la journée et en en
fin en fin de journée sera tout à fait
apte à se faire une une bonne idée entre
10h et 20h salon des livres à
saint-ciire l'école au LCÉE militaire
une toute dernière question votre livre
à vous de chevet en ce moment votre
livre coup de cœur mon livre coup de
cœur à Edgar fort de de bah de son
Petitfils
openheimer qui est un qui est très
intéressant secret de famille secret
d'état on trouve de choses assez assez
piquantes et l'actualité euh se
l'histoire se se renouvelle toujours et
Edgar fort est encore très présent chez
nous merci Philippe de bcoup d'être venu
sur ce plateau du 78 lactu merci
infiniment prochain journal demain
vendredi il sera principalement question
de rythme scolaire à la veille d'une
grande mobilisation des élus des parents
d'élèves aussi hostiles à la réforme qui
se déroulera à Paris et puis nous
reviendrons sur l'essentiel de
l'information de la semaine forcément
excellente
[Musique]
soirée
[Applaudissements]